all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to my morning coffee thoughts
where I give my thoughts over morning
coffee before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in and also get
yourself a women shouldn't vote shirt
none of these problems would have
happened if women didn't get the right
to vote uh we're also going to come out
with some women shouldn't drive we're
always texting and driving you know and
also um a repeal the 19th shirt so the
link to that it'll be in the description
but if you don't have that it's the
audacity network. store that's the
audacity network. store so um today what
I wanted to talk about is how the red
pill is absolutely different than
feminism so one um cope that I often see
from and it's really annoying I actually
find this very annoying all of these um
red pill people um um will an
influencers will make money off of red
pills so they'll they'll come in and
they'll look at the the original guy's
work you know Rolo some of these other
guys work and and they'll take parts of
it right make money off of it but then
what they'll do is six months later
they'll like turn because honestly the
end of the red pill
guys it's not an easy message to sell if
you're looking at predicting the future
not what should or shouldn't happen in
societ but what is likely going to
happen it's really not a grim future or
it's not like a happy future and I don't
say this like I'm happy about it I don't
say this like I'm super excited that
it's going to happen there were points
where I denied it where I was like well
this isn't going to happen but um at
some point you kind of just accept
what's
true and what I'm about to tell you is
absolutely true I would bet all the
money that I have that this is is going
to happen so unless there is a societal
shift but I'll get to that so the red
pill is used in a lot of different terms
there's a lot of different ways people
use this but let's just talk about the
truth about intersexual
Dynamics and the truth of the matter is
right now marriage doesn't exist we are
in a post-marriage
society but we don't know it yet a lot
of people are still living in the past
so what happen happened was about um
when I was in high school about 8th
grade social media came and I would say
from when I started High School to After
High School I kind of saw the shift of
people living more and more online and
as we got to be a more and more online
age women we had access to the top shelf
men right so average normal looking
girls could get DMS from Drake now a lot
of you guys will think well and this I
used to have these thoughts too I would
think well I was never invited on a
yacht like where were these yacht
parties right um so it might not
necessarily be Drake okay or like
whatever Kanye whatever celebrity we're
going to use but think about the fact
that some of these guys have slept with
a thousand women some have slept with 50
some have slept with 20 that's 20 wives
that are going to get married later and
when you start thinking about these like
real numbers of wom like I mean Drake
gets his bras thrown at him on stage
these are women a lot of times that go
off to get
married and the problem is the problem
with all that is in history we have
always had institutions in place to stop
women from leaving the peasant for the
king because female nature and this
isn't like a fun fact about female
nature is if we think we can get
commitment and resources from the King
we're going to leave don't know why but
like women we just have patterns okay
and you'll see this even among Elite
like aristocratic women where they did
Monkey Branch they did cheap because
they're around all the kings right and
women we just have this tendency to
always want to do better and never happy
don't know why and um okay so social
media comes in and all the US women now
are being marketed to 24/7 so 24 hours a
day we have all this media telling us
it's okay to be fat you're amazing it's
okay to sleep around you're not a
and guys if you're hearing this message
from the time you're
12 um to maybe 35 when reality hits Us
in the face you're going to believe it
and the thing about women if if if you
get in our ear long enough we just start
to believe stuff I don't know what it is
about us and that's why you see like in
the younger polls women becoming more
liberal men becoming more conservative
men aren't as you know they'll question
things they're not as likely to buy
stuff they're more likely to say oh no
no I'm not with that so now let's kind
of dive into the divorce stats and a lot
of people will accuse me of being Doom
and Gloom but really I just look at the
numbers um right now
only 50% of people stay married so
there's a 50/50 divorce rate and let's
be honest guys is the reputation of
marriage good no and a lot of times with
the right do is they'll have like a
shaming tactic they or they'll left to
and they'll say like oh
well I mean it's just the people you're
around da d d I think you kind of have
to deny reality if you don't see people
in and out of the church and good
communities and bad communities getting
divorced and hating each other because
if it was a good reputation if marriage
was this thing that nobody that people
wanted to do that had a good reputation
um then it wouldn't have the reputation
it has you know whose fault is it for
the reputation it says something about
it so 50% of marriages fail the majority
of people do not have a good view on
marriage so let's say half of the people
that get
married um hate each
other that's a 75% failure rate that
means you're more likely to fail so
that's in marriage now you know Morgan
Stanley is predicting half of my
generation of women are going to be
single and childless 45% of us so what
this means is that half of us are going
to not get
married and the other half of us are
going to be that that do get married
half will get divorced and out of the
other half that stay married half of
them are going to be miserable so what
what is that like a 10 20%
so knowing this now we look at the men's
side of things like you got to think
about this from the men's
side right now women have all the power
in society um now you could argue maybe
it's men's fault for giving it to them
but most men today had zero say in what
happened a 100 years ago none of them
had any like this isn't the system we're
born into was none of our faults you
know I I could even argue women are
addicted to so social media um because
this is the time period we grew up in
right okay
so knowing all this information being a
guy why would you want to get married
and this was something that was really
hard for me to accept as a chick where
I'm like wow like I was sold this dream
right where everyone's got one person
and everyone's going to be married but
really if you look at under 40
um there's not a lot of
marriages uh the really last generation
of marriages is the 40 to 60y Old the
under 40 uh social media kind of made
everything a different time the women
kind of all crazy um so all right now we
look at this this is a very and then you
get two groups there's the groups that
say hey guys we have to resist this we
need to come out on top and typically
these are good-looking men um that
really don't represent the average man
in America they don't represent the coal
miners they don't represent the factory
workers they don't represent the bus
drivers and the all of this stuff or or
their streamer that is my that is my
biggest pet peeve when the the these red
pill guys that are are
streamers professional
talkers oh my God like I do it oh my God
so it like and I'm not saying like it is
hard to make it on social media but
let's not pretend that the these guys
have like or anyone that that's on
social media has this exceptional
character that a bus driver a trucker
does not have that we are so much more
hardworking than the average men that
build these societies okay
so right okay so now you have the
average man the average man is
unattractive to women women find 80% of
men is unattractive so maybe they'll
find the top 20% of men is hot the next
20% of men is okay and let's just say
he's a four or five he's a factory
worker four or five average
guy why in his eyes would he not walk
away from marriage and relationships so
right now the government is basically
taking money and giving it to women
through either government programs or
um or um either through government
programs or uh basically useless jobs so
they they give us these jobs jobs in HR
secretary work I mean secretaries aren't
useless but like let's be honest guys
let's call it what it is a lot of women
are making money off of the faces a lot
of my women are make we're making money
off of being pretty it's not that we're
doing so much work it's not that we're
so competent they have diversity hires
and there are smart women I'm not taking
that away you know I like to think I'm a
hard worker I like to think I'm smart
but you know
um probably not not as smart as a guy in
my same position I'm just being honest
you know
so okay why would the average guy sign
up for a system and resist the system
that is really stacked against him when
I just broke down those marriage numbers
for you it's not really a doom and gloom
person to say well there's really only a
10 20% chance of success here and the
average woman finds the average guy is
ugly um the and then we look at body
count stats you know know um virgins
have an 80% chance of a happy marriage
if you've slept with more than five
Partners it's like 20% so now a guy
knows okay that on average 96% of women
are not virgins I'm probably not going
to get a virgin um I'm not really going
to know her body count but I I nowadays
they're higher than ever I think the
average is between like five and
nineish um that's on the more lower
stats higher stats say between 15 to 25
uh we don't know right women will lie to
the grave
but so he looks at this and he says huh
all right so I basically get a fat
average woman's 170 lbs in history we'd
all be thrown out right and I could
marry her and start a
family but you know now this whole
system stacked against me if it doesn't
work out the last 20 years of working
she can just take my money and even if
we have kids she could talk about me to
the kids and then they'll hate me and
like like these are the things guys
think about they weigh the pros and they
weigh the cons and right now the cons
are just super high and that's why I I
say you know I can't blame men for
saying you know what I'm going to get a
vasectomy and just get out I'm only
going to deal with these chicks
recreationally I also can't blame men
for wanting to have a family you know
and and wanting to take that risk I I
that's fair too and they'll say well you
can't just walk away from a system
that's stacked against you I would I
would beg to ask why they can't um and
the difference between feminism is
feminism is asking for all of the
freedom without any of the
responsibility right and some of the
mtow red pill really is just saying make
your choice no choices are wrong because
this is a tough system and red pill
basically
says well you guys have all of the
responsibility you have the freedom to
do whatever you want if you want to get
married and do that do it if you want to
get a vasectomy and walk away do it if
you want to only deal with these chicks
recreationally do it because right now
you guys are doing all the work you're
paying all the taxes you're doing all
the hard jobs you have all the
responsibility so you should have the
freedom to do what you want and these
women aren't your problem you already
pay for them through the state in these
useless jobs um now
this isn't a fun conclusion to come
to it is way easier to come on here and
say guys the solution is family the
solution is marriage that just resist
this system um I don't see any of that
happening until they change the divorce
laws so really it's like you could go be
an Amish most guys don't want to be
Amish um you which you know you could go
be a passport
bro um but a lot of times they bring
these chicks back here they have some of
the same problems and social media
really all these other countries in my
opinion are just like 20 years behind
America um yeah like it's coming it's
going to ruin everybody um or we go back
I would argue to more patriarchal system
or men really decide what is good and
isn't good for us and we submit to the
authority of the men in our home and we
submit to the authority of the men in
society um but right now the difference
is feminism all the freedom no
responsibility we don't want to do any
of the taxes we don't want to do any of
the hard jobs but we want to be married
and have a happy ending at 37 with two
different baby daddies that's feminism
red pill is saying hey this system is
against you these women are complete
crazies and I don't blame you for any
solution and and the different red pill
guys of different solutions so I'll give
you an example one that I I hear a lot
is myin sleep with 50 women now guys
Pearl is not saying to do this I I
rather try to understand where people
from coming are coming from and what's
lost in society is really trying to
understand where someone's coming from
without pushing it like I'm not pushing
anything and um so he'll say sleep with
50 women and if a girl doesn't sleep
with you on the first date um then get
rid of her now why does he say this and
instead of it's so funny I I used to get
triggered by this too the reason he says
this is because the average chick has
slept with multiple dudes and if she's
not sleeping with you she's probably
sleeping with someone what did happened
with Nina Agdal she we made Logan wait
but was she sleeping with someone else
kind of seems that way I I don't know
you know I feel bad people have just
been piling on this chick but
um you know so and the other thing is
there are predatory women now now
there's a lot of women that run game and
you see these predatory dating coaches
teach you how to run game and get a s
that doesn't know any better and you
could argue well men don't need to sleep
around no better just find a good woman
okay what churches really have a good
reputation of the women in them um you
know at some point all of these studies
da d d mean nothing because we can
really come to conclusions based on
society and the truth is there's a
reason you know I'm I'm Catholic sorry
Catholics there's a reason we have
phrases like Catholic school girl
there's a reason that we have phrases
like The Preacher's Daughter you know
these aren't good
connotations and the truth of the matter
is if if churches had a good reputation
for making wives the men would be lined
up they there would be you don't think
men they make ladies nights for men if
if the churches produced amazing wives
there would be a line and so what the
church people will do is hey we have
these amazing women in church and the
guys will check it out and be like no
these are crazy and then they'll
be like what they'll they'll get all mad
and be like well the men are leaving the
church and I'm like look guys and this
is this is where we got to look in the
mirror there needs to be the churches
need to actively seek out men they need
to start stop pay pingg to the women and
stop start pandering to the men and not
even pandering because you can't Pander
to men that's the funny thing too all
these sass guys will tell me oh you're
just pandering grifting there's no I
don't well I mean people can say things
they don't believe but the thing is you
can't really get a huge male following
spewing um you can really only
do that with women men are much more
logical than women unless they're super
feminine um you know and and then what
they do is they put a feminine like
point of view on young men they'll be
like well they're they're they're young
men being led astray no that's more
women men are pretty logical that's why
men have been walking away from Marriage
for like 15 years now because they saw
what happened
before and yeah so that's the difference
between red pill and feminism so
feminism I'll show you so there's a
natural order of the world I believe God
men
women
children right and right now we have
these two switched in society so right
now the women are above the men that's
out of order right the women are above
the men that's that's wrong out of order
and if the men say I don't want to be a
part of the system that is completely
out of
order then they're called a red pill
Doomer black pill whatever
yes there are good women but I think as
a whole you're not going to see women
switch until there are consequences
because the truth of the matter is when
women get power for whatever reason we
just don't tend to be good people since
we've gotten the right to vote we have
had predatory um criminal justice laws
divorce laws child support law all that
stuff um has been bad so for whatever
reason as a group we don't pick that so
until women don't have um as much power
I really don't see things changing and I
think it's reasonable for men to want to
walk away if they want I think it's
reasonable and I'm I personally would
not try to do these stupid shaming
tactics because they don't want to do
what I think is you know what my ideal
world is anyways um let me know what you
guys think in the comments like the
video subscribe to the channel um make
sure you ring that notification Bell
I'll talk to you next time